In this video,
we'll discuss the relationship between
the linear chain conditional random
fields with the hidden Markov model.
Okay.
So, uh, we've, uh,
in a previous video talked about whether
there were alternatives to the linear
chain conditional then field for sequence.
So classification a of alternatives that
might be more appropriate when we have
a lot of training data.
Yeah.
This has led us to talk about the
maximum entropy Markov model. And A,
I've mentioned why,
uh,
it suffered from a problem known as the
labeled bias problem where observation
for the wind,
the sequence would actually not have
any impact on the prediction and the
marginal probability for the label
at positions early in the sequence.
So in other alternative to the MDM
EMM, which is well known that you, uh,
and we've actually,
uh,
meant mentioned in passing in previous
videos is the hidden Markov model.
So a,
in the hidden Markov model,
instead of assuming a generative started
where we are given some inputs and
those inputs in the sequence
and then generated the labels,
we have an inverted
generative story where we, uh,
the labels at first been produced.
And then from the labels,
the sequence of observations, I've
actually been produced from this soul.
And instead of of producing
the inputs and then the labels,
it's the other way around.
And actually in Hmms,
we usually define a, uh, uh,
something know that as the,
uh, uh, uh, emission distribution,
which tells us how the inputs were
generated from the labels. So p of x,
given why. So, uh, from this,
we actually get a full joint
distribution over both y and x,
both the sequence of labels
and the sequence of, uh, uh,
of inputs. And if we have a
joint probability from this,
then we can just compute
p of y given x by, uh,
just dividing by the
marginal probability of x,
which means that we can have an expression
for minus the log of the conditional
probability of y given x.
And we could try to optimize that.
And so I essentially optimize our model
to assign high conditional probability
on the labels, uh, given
the inputs. So, uh,
uh,
this training of Hmms is a,
actually used a lot in speech recognition.
It's known as maximum Mitchell
information training. Uh, and, uh,
we can show that we don't have the
same label bias problem anymore.
So that's an advantage.
However,
the director nature of the hmm can make
it a bit more complicated to train.
So optimization the optimization
problem associated with training, uh,
it can become a bit more complicated
because if you write down the,
hmm as a factor,
a model where it's a product of factors,
as we've discussed before, the factors
now need to be normalized probabilities.
And so this has certain consequences in
the optimization of the model. And a,
it can also be a somewhat difficult
to define a good distribution over the
sequence of inputs x if the
vectors x one x two. And so on.
Our real valued vectors,
defining distribution of a
rail real value vector is,
is actually not a trivial thing to do.
Whereas in crs,
because their conditional,
we totally sidestep this problem and a
yet we don't actually suffer from the
label pious problem, much like
in a descriptive. Hmm. So, uh,
one can think of a conditional random
fields and interchain conditional random
feel as the sort of best of both worlds
solution between a discriminative hidden
Markov model and the maximum
entropy markup model. So,
um,
so to sum up a while,
the maximum entropy Markov model can be
perhaps easier to train than the hidden
Markov model.
It suffers from the label bias problem
and the end of the mark of model,
if which words you're training
descriptively though it's possible,
and people do it. And
speech recognition, uh,
it can be harder than the linear
chain conditional and the Va..